david la situation était tendue tout à
l'heure on l'a vu avec vous où en est-on
maintenant eh bien écoutez ce fiel
opérations de blocage se poursuit ici
l'installation de tentes comme pouvait
pas comme vous pouvez le voir derrière
moi se mettre en place
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée un
cette opération de blocage impact
énormément sur la récolte de déchets
parisien on parle de 3000 tonnes de
déchets parisien environ par jour est
bien ici on en tête on en traite 2000
ici 2000 par jour dans cet incinérateur
d'yves rire un chiffre énorme
l'opération de blocage va se poursuivre
toute la journée avec un objectif clair
la sphère continuer en tout cas pendant
plusieurs jours c'est ce que plusieurs
syndicalistes m'ont dit des poteaux en
métal ont été installés sur les grilles
pour éviter aux gens de rentrer dans
l'enceinte même de l'incinérateur
je vous propose d'écouter génial en
vercors ginza co-organisateur de cette
opération de blocage
on voit là ce jour que les salariés sont
déterminés à aux pros retrait du projet
de loi est donc évidemment sur le site
on avait des taux de grévistes qui
al'argent attend le retour mais on
tourne entre 70 et 80% de grévistes
depuis le début du mouvement donc on
voit bien que les gens sont
plein entier dans le mouvement est donc
aujourd'hui la gère la situation parce
qu'on voit bien que il ya des conduites
et il ya aujourd'hui demain après demain
et donc c'est un vrai rapport de force
qui est en train de se mettre en place
aujourd'hui les gens sont plutôt
déterminer qu'on retire le projet qu'on
discuterait allemand du fonds mais à
partir de vraies propositions qu'on peut
nous apporter la cgt et ça a été rappelé
plusieurs fois avec philippe martinez
est donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment
mobilisés pour justement faire en sorte
que et ben le gouvernant entendre
réellement les salariés est aujourd'hui
aussi l'opinion publique est plutôt
favorable sur le sur le mouvement qui
ont donc son cours ils sont une centaine
de syndicalistes est ici à s'être réunis
à l'incinérateur d'ivry 1 pour pouvoir
protester contre ce projet de réforme
des retraites avec un objectif clair
évidemment le retrait pur et simple de
ce projet de loi est le blocage se
poursuit donc ici à toute la journée
pour pouvoir espérer en tout cas le
faire perdurer dans le temps et un
maximum de joueurs pour bloquer en tout
cas l'accès des camions c'est une
centaine de camions qui seront d ici à
chaque jour des camions de déchets pour
apporter leurs déchets vers
l'incinérateur
le but est de bloquer un maximum ces
camions pour pouvoir bloquer évidemment
l'accès à l'incinérateur deal ainsi à
l'incinérateur pour pouvoir à brûler les
déchets